alors je vais vous dire ce weekend TF1
était ton panique total parce que j'ai
donné des chiffres sur combien coûtait
l'émission alors
ils sont pas ils ont rien dit sur les
chiffres ils ont dit oui on donne pas
100000 aux invités je dis qu'ils ont eu
100000 aux invités quand je dis 100000
aux invités
c'est bien simple c'est quand ils font
venir un groupe de Los Angeles je peux
vous dire que ça leur coûte énormément
d'argent l'info que j'ai elle est
pratiquement sûr et certaine les
viennent de démonter ils ont dit que
c'était 250000 par émission je pense que
c'est 500 000 la journée voilà la
journée je sais pas si il tourne une ou
deux émissions peut-être qu'il tombe
deux émissions par jour mais je vous dis
mes infos étaient donc les bonnes
puisque c'est 500 000 la journée j'avais
peut-être oublié de préciser que c'était
la journée voilà et c'est 500 000 voilà
par jour vous faites votre calcul
comment ça fait combien ça peut coûter
etc après moi je veux dire un truc à TF1
ils font ce qu'ils veulent qui veulent
donner 500 000 s'ils veulent donner 4
millions s'ils veulent donner 8 millions
font ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas de
l'argent public moi je suis franchement
je donne mon émission média ici on donne
des infos forcément il y a des groupes
qui vont venir des Los Angeles qui font
venir de tous les pays où je peux vous
dire que ça coûte de l'argent les mecs
ils voyagent pas en ce moment les gars
je peux vous dire ils vont pas à l'hôtel
ils vont pas aller à l'étape hôtel donc
forcément ça non mais c'est ça donc
forcément ça coûte de l'argent donc
c'est bien 500 000 jours je vous dis et
jours et il y a une enveloppe pour les
inviter de danse les invités de chant
donc les chanteurs qui font venir les
voilà les acteurs ils sont pas payés le
reste
un jour du jardin il est pas payé c'est
sûr après voilà
exactement après peut-être que peut-être
qu'il y a un petit défraiement mais en
tout cas je vous dis tous les gens qui
viennent danser tous les gens qui
viennent chanter ils sont payés c'est
sûr et certain donc ce sont des invités
il y a tous les jours un invité voilà je
vous dis et ça coûte de l'argent donc
voilà c'est 500000 jours donc et je peux
vous dire ils l'ont dit 250000 voilà je
sais déjà énorme donc voilà donc 500000
jours pour l'émission voilà puisqu'ils
dedans la journée voilà donc après ils
étaient pas bien sachez que voilà avec
TF1 il y a pas de guerre on se parle
voilà alors on se parlait pas maintenant
on se parle mais sinon parce que quand
on dit quelque chose sur eux le plus
important
on va pas se mentir les chéris c'est
l'audience c'est incroyable parce que
moi je m'en fous que ça marche ou pas
Alain Chabat ça marche rien à [ __ ] je
suis pas en face ça marche on l'aurait
dit si ça avait marché quand le Burger
Quiz a marché on a dit ici je peux
ressortir les images c'est un énorme
carton là égale il fait 800000 sur TF1
c'est une catastrophe industrielle mais
ils veulent nous faire croire ce qui me
rend fou moi c'est la comme autour de ça
c'est à dire qu'ils ne vole pas avouer
qu'ils ont printool moi quand je prends
des tôles et j'en ai pris je reprendrai
je dirais oui j'avoue cette émission n'a
pas marché j'ai pris une to les gens
rigolerai eux ils veulent pas ils
veulent que ils veulent ils sont dans le
déni même Raymond qui connaît pas bien
les chiffres quand ils voient Alain
Chabat 8,3% par de marché 800000
téléspectateurs sur TF1 après un match
qui a fait 6 millions tu sais quoi ton
analyse bah moi c'est pareil je me dis
comme pourquoi tu pourquoi tu as vidé la
salle comme ça pourquoi les gens sont
partis après faut pas qu'ils aient honte
que l'émission C'est 500000 €. si si
vraiment ton émission elle est
magnifique si vraiment c'est le lac
d'Alain Chabat assume que ça coûte 500
000 tu t'en fous tu dis ça coûte 500 000
et je vous emmerde et ça fait 800000 et
je vous emmène si vous n'êtes pas
content changer de chaîne toute façon
vous changer une réponse dans Le
Parisien ils ont fait une interview dans
le Parisien Leight avec Alain Chabat
audience budget images quel premier
bilan pour TF1 donc c'est TF1 qui fait
bilan moi si non le bilan de Séville je
vais dire tout est extraordinaire
forcément je vais dire barnabis hein
j'ai dit tu vois pas non mais c'est vrai
producteur d'émission très sympa donc il
dit
5250000 € par émission donc ça fait
500000 joues c'est dans ton monde donc
voilà on est d'accord 500000 jours les
invités ne sont pas payés voilà mais je
vous dis c'est les groupes les groupes
sont payés je le sais on a les infos et
c'est pas grave mais nous aussi
des fois et on a pas honte de le dire
oui voilà et ça c'est ça qui est énorme
cette émission est un cadeau de Noël que
l'on a fait à nos téléspectateurs
ils ont pas été très nombreux à aller le
rechercher et on est très content des
résultats sur les cibles jeunes comme
les 25-49 et des centaines de milliers
de visionnages sur les réseaux sociaux
pour les pastilles les plus amusants
quand tu dis ça c'est que tu sais que tu
as pris une banane
quand tu commences à aller chercher les
réseaux sociaux attends sur un stage
j'ai fait un million de vues sur une
vidéo donc les mecs on s'en fout nous
attendons
ils ont l'impression que ça nous fait
plaisir non mais on s'en fout que ça
marche ou pas on est très content Jérôme
rebond c'est un pote et marre avec lui
on me rebond producteur de l'émission
Alain Chabat c'est vrai qu'on est pas
les meilleurs amis du monde mais il est
pas en face de moi on s'en fout il fait
son truc sur TF1 c'est juste qu'on donne
une information claire et précise ça
marche pas ça marche pas Rizlaine non
mais oui non mais bien sûr Touche pas à
mon poste vous donner les informations
les audiences etc mais moi je comprends
pas est-ce que ça mérite qu'on saisisse
l'arcom non mais c'est ça
c'est quand même c'est quand même
surréaliste en fait et puis il faut pas
se voiler la face c'est un naufrage
cette émission je veux dire qu'on aime à
l'achat bas ou pas c'est un naufrage on
est d'accord voilà merci
énormément de choses de cette émission
mais après qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour
pas que je reste sur cette émission là
j'ai regardé est-ce que c'est nul pour
pas avoir une mauvaise souvenir après
les matchs de Jean-Pierre l'émission
Denis Brognard déjà qui commence à être
une hémorragie
quand les gens reviennent après 23h je
vais te dire je vais t'expliquer la télé
expliquez-moi parce que moi la télé
c'est pas le nombre de téléspectateurs
qui comptent à 23 ans c'est la part de
marché c'est le nombre de personnes qui
regardent cette émission en pourcentage
par rapport aux autres émissions quand
tu t'appelles Alain Chabat et que tu as
23h 23h normalement tu dois te gaver
pourquoi moi je pousse mes émissions
très tard parce qu'à 23h tu as plus rien
en face et que ta PDA elle va monter à
20 à 25 30 35 40 quant à 8 de PDA c'est
que personne ne veut regarder Mathieu
qui connaît bien la télé non je
reconnais que ça va beaucoup et surtout
mes 15 je reconnais que c'est très très
faible ils ont battu par M6
c'est pas le nombre je reconnais que
c'est c'est je pense qu'il faut dire la
vérité c'est un échec en audience ça
c'est vrai après on images tu es une
très belle émission quota Bellucci quant
à Jean Dujardin quand tu as des gens
comme ça et pourquoi pas voilà mais en
revanche tu peux dire qu'effectivement
et le plateau éclate je pense que
personne ne s'attendait à 15 % ménagère
ce serait possible que ça cartonne je te
l'ai dit désolé je te l'ai dit ou pas
c'est vrai je t'ai dit ça va cartonner
c'est une belle émission ça marche pas
après c'est le recycle ils ont refait
canal sur TF1 TF1 c'est une chaîne c'est
compliqué de mettre canal sur la chaîne
Mimie Mathy c'est pas pareil les choses
c'est pas du vent je veux dire Alain
Chabat comme il a fait sa promo il
expliquait oui on va pas parler
d'actualité mais allez ciao la base d'un
lait chaud c'est parler d'actualité tu
peux pas faire la lecture enregistré
mais non c'est pour ça que je disais
parle devant
toi je parlais d'argent parce qu'en vrai
si vous avez fait l'émission en direct
elle aurait fait deux fois plus
d'audience voir plus
mais le problème c'est que là ils ont
voulu tout faire en batterie et prendre
500.000 euros par jour c'est 500000
euros par jour il a dit là voilà donc un
moment et bah tu peux tu dois tout
mettre en boîte tu fais les 10 émissions
tu prends 5 millions d'euros en 10 jours
en 5 jours et en 5 millions d'euros en 5
jours puisqu'il y avait 10 numéros 5
millions d'euros 5 jours Mathieu ça te
ferai en 10 jours en 10 jours non non tu
me dis que c'était 250000 l'émission
pour des émissions donc tu prends 5
jours tu prends 2 millions et demi parce
que tu fais tu fais des sacs tu fais des
émissions 5 jours donc en une semaine tu
prends deux minutes et ben voilà alors
on va voir un extrait tu parlais du lait
regardez
devoir deviner des titres de chansons de
Noël alors attention premier morceau
essayez de reconnaître ce champ de Noël
[Musique]
pour l'instant là ça c'est les paroles
ça c'est les paroles est-ce que j'ai
oublié de vous dire pardon
et on me confirme il y a des invités qui
viennent gratuitement et les groupes
sont payés bien entendu oui la réaction
elle est complètement lunaire dans cette
émission c'était 12 ans vous commentez
la télé que vous la critiquez bien ou en
mal j'ai pas le souvenir qu'on a un
communiqué de presse un article de
démentier dans Le Parisien à chaque fois
la vérité c'est que cette émission
surface on a critiqué français
qui sont pas à l'aise avec cette
émission qui pensait que ça allait être
un énorme succès et que c'est un bide et
que je pense que ça les rendrait
beaucoup plus humain et beaucoup plus
sympathique de reconnaître que ça marche
aussi ça ne marche pas il fait une vidéo
ça marche pas on s'en fout on va rigoler
on s'en fout qu'est-ce qu'on s'en fout
ça je veux les communiquer sur des
succès c'est la vieille télé c'est
exactement regarde-moi
alors Léa Drucker bonsoir donc 60 ans de
télé vous êtes toujours là
vous adorez les chiens et vous filer le
parfait amour depuis 45 ans avec Dany
Saval
attendez c'est sérieux ça c'est votre
vanne si vous me confondez avec Michel
Drucker
alors allez-y continuez alors est-ce que
quand vous avez une grosse semaine de
boulot il vous arrive de dire parfois
[ __ ] vivement dimanche
on arrête on arrête
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que vous
pouvez m'expliquer des trucs qu'on a été
sympa
aussi c'était la communication il aurait
fallu expliquer aux gens qu'en fait ce
sont des sketchs comme les nuls à
l'époque c'est une émission de sketch et
nous on attendait une émission il y aura
une interview il y aurait de l'actualité
est-ce qu'on peut m'expliquer juste un
truc parce que moi je suis dégoûté
depuis 10-15 ans je ne vois plus de
stars à la télé ils veulent plus venir
aux emails je ne vois plus de ça dans
une dans Star arrêtez dans aucune
émission je vois plus de stars comme il
a eu lui si on les a pas payés comment
ça se fait qu'ils ont tous réussi à
venir chez lui ils ont même plus le
droit ils ont même même pas aux [ __ ]
les mecs ils disent qu'ils ont plus le
temps
c'est le journal de télé ça là tu dis
des conneries je dis pas des conneries
ramène-moi une émission
quand même je vais quand même payer
d'argent donnez-moi où ils ont autant de
stars alors tant mieux c'est très bien
l'antenne
depuis 10 ans
je suis votre chat alors j'aimerais je
vous le dis ce soir puisque j'ai vu que
le parisien Le Parisien ils sont
incroyable il demande à TF1 de faire
leur propre bilan ok tu vois TF1 et dire
euh non franchement c'est c'est pourri
on fait des audiences de merde ils ont
toujours le Parisien a toujours été
encore plus en ce moment je vais dire à
la sole c'est méchant pour le Parisien
mais maquer presque associé à TF1 et
c'est vrai que Guillaume a raison la
force de la réaction de TF1 du plan
Chabat montre le malaise ils sont venus
hystérique quoi donc je vous le dis
comme communiquer c'est surréaliste ça
coûte 500 000 jours c'est tout c'est
comme ça et
je voudrais qu'on accueille je vous dis
j'ai pris un gars de fou voilà on va
appeler un des spécialistes des médias
il est avec nous ce soir il va nous dire
vraiment pour lui si ça marche ou pas
c'est un des plus grands spécialistes
des médias en France c'est parti
Michelin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir Monsieur bonsoir je vais
dérouler son son CV vous allez dire bon
c'est un truc de fou il a co-créé le mec
comme Marti international des programmes
de communication il est consultant il a
été consultant artistique sur scène mon
mardi avec Christophe Dechavanne
directeur des programmes de TV5 Monde
directeur des magazines de la raie uno
en Italie consultant et analyste pour
Mediamétrie directeur de rédaction de la
rubrique Médias de Télé Poche aide au
développement de la télévision numérique
terrestre membre du Conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel conseiller stratégique au
sein du groupe Bertelsman RTL M6 Prisma
et vous avez écrit plusieurs ouvrages
sur la télé alors instable monsieur
Carna au vu de votre expérience et de
vos compétences ou pose une question que
pensez-vous des audiences du lait chaud
dans la Chabat sur TF1 les audiences
c'est catastrophique merci
[Applaudissements]